[Música]
en Estados Unidos el FBI arrestó al
Principal sospechoso de la filtración de
los documentos del pentágono se trata
del líder del grupo online de Gamers
religiosos y aficionados a las armas
donde se publicaron por primera vez los
archivos el hombre de 21 años era
miembro de la inteligencia de la guardia
aérea Tenemos reporte desde Washington
en Francia jornada número 2 se de
protestas contra la reforma pensional de
Manuel macron Los sindicatos convocaron
las marchas un día antes de que el
consejo constitucional decida sobre la
legalidad del texto según el gobierno la
participación cayó a menos de 400.000
personas en todo el país
Ucrania se plantea su ingreso a la otan
como única opción para la seguridad
futura del país al tiempo que instala
Alianza aumentar su presencia militar en
el mar Negro a través de una estrategia
conjunta en respuesta Rusia plantea no
renovar el acuerdo de exportación de
granos que expira el 18 de mayo
Buenas tardes bienvenidos las noticias
de Frank 24 en español Soy Rosa y es
para mí un gusto acompañarles abrimos
esta edición informativa en Estados
Unidos con la noticia del día y es que
el FBI ha detenido a un sospechoso por
la filtración masiva de documentos
secretos del pentágono se trata de un
hombre de 21 años identificado como
jackera miembro de la inteligencia de la
guardia aérea de Massachusetts y que
lideraba el grupo online de Gamers
religiosos y aficionados a las armas
donde se publicaron por primera vez los
archivos clasificados antes de
propagarse por otros portales de
internet El fiscal general de Estados
Unidos confirmó la detención
el departamento de justicia arrestó a
Jack douglass en relación con una
investigación sobre la supuesta
extracción retención y transmisión no
autorizada de información clasificada de
defensa nacional compartiendola como
empleado de la guardia Nacional de la
fuerza aérea de los Estados Unidos
previamente nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos explicó
Qué consecuencias legales enfrenta el
sospechoso de la filtración que el
pentágono calificó de acto criminal
deliberado
grandes consecuencias legales por cada
documento que fue filtrado Se podría ir
a afrontar hasta 10 años de cárceles es
decir podría incluso llegar hasta la
cadena perpetua contando la cantidad de
documentos que se filtraron que pusieron
en en la lupa las las actividades de
espionaje de Estados Unidos y obviamente
lo que está diciendo el fiscal general
el departamento de Justicia es que pues
será acusado de espionaje el acta de
espionaje que no solamente pone en
riesgo la seguridad de Estados Unidos
sino que le da ventaja con esta
información a enemigos de Estados Unidos
así que diez años por cada papel que fue
filtrado podría afrontar Este joven por
haber filtrado estos documentos que
efectivamente como lo dice el pentágono
independientemente de cual haya sido la
motivación de haber compartido esta
información confidencial pues no se
justifica y lo que están diciendo muchos
acá en Washington en el congreso y en la
casa blanca incluso biden desde Irlanda
dijo que tiene que haber una revisión
exhausta exhaustiva sobre Cuáles son los
mecanismos para acceder a esta
información y quién exactamente está
accediendo a esta información
confidencial que termina en la mano de
pues adultos jóvenes como termina
compartiéndolo en redes sociales y se
termina siendo viral y continúa la
batalla legal en Estados Unidos por el
acceso a las píldoras abortivas el
fiscal general anunció que el
departamento de Justicia va a recurrir
ante la Corte Suprema la decisión de
ayer de un tribunal de apelaciones que
preservó temporalmente el acceso a la
píldora pero con restricciones con este
proceso Además está en juego La
autoridad de la fda para imponer el
criterio científico en la autorización
de medicamentos
y en otras noticias en Francia se
desarrolló la jornada número 12 de
protestas contra la impopular reforma de
las pensiones de Manuel macron un día
antes de que el consejo constitucional
decida si el texto está amparado por la
Constitución de la quinta República
francesa según el Ministerio del
interior 380.000 personas habrían
participado este jueves en las protestas
a nivel nacional Mientras que el
sindicato cgt eleva la cifra a más de un
millón En todo caso ha habido una bajada
de la participación respecto a la
jornada anterior previamente nuestra
periodista en París Natalia Ruiz no
reportó los detalles de la jornada y lo
que se espera de mañana
esta jornada de manifestación número 12
se desarrolla de manera muy similar a
las anteriores con algunos disturbios a
lo largo de El recorrido y sobre todo al
punto ya final Como por ejemplo aquí en
la Plaza de la bastilla donde la policía
ha utilizado gases a lacrimógenos para
dispersar algunos manifestantes según
los sindicatos en la capital marcharon
cuatrocientas mil personas una cifra que
el Ministerio del interior dividió por
10 tan solo 42.000 según las autoridades
francesas En todo caso la continuidad de
todas estas movilizaciones desde hace
más de tres meses Está suspendida a lo
que ocurra este viernes con la decisión
de el consejo constitucional que
determinará si el texto de la Reforma
pensional es exigible o no Ya sea en su
totalidad o tan solo parcialmente los
sindicatos han dicho que una vez
conozcan esta decisión a comienzos de la
próxima semana determinarán Cuál es el
plazo a seguir pero también todos están
muy pendientes de si el consejo va a dar
o no luz
a que se realice un referendo y se
someta al voto popular pues toda esta
reforma pensional Pero para esto habrá
que conseguir antes prácticamente cinco
millones de firmas por parte de los
electores franceses ese es uno de los
requisitos varios de los sindicatos han
dicho que están seguros que los pueden
conseguir y que bien van a ponerse en
esta tarea mientras se conoce esa
decisión el presidente de Manuel macan
dijo que ya a finales de este viernes
una vez se conozca Entonces ese
veredicto del Consejo Pues citará a los
sindicatos a una reunión en los próximos
días
y en dublín en un discurso ante el
parlamento Irlandés el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden pidió a Reino
Unido que trabaje más de cerca con la
República de Irlanda para evitar el
resurgimiento del conflicto nori
Irlandés recordemos que biden emprendió
una visita oficial por la isla de
Irlanda para conmemorar los 25 años de
la firma de los llamados acuerdos de
viernes Santo un entendimiento mediado
por Washington que que puso fin a
décadas de conflicto armado nacional
religioso en Irlanda del Norte entre los
republicanos partidarios de unirse a la
República de Irlanda y los loialistas
los que quieren permanecer en el Reino
Unido
y actualizamos ahora las noticias de la
Guerra de Ucrania porque ante la
petición de kiev de una mayor presencia
de la otan en el mar Negro Rusia se
declara reacia extender el acuerdo de
granos un acuerdo que sí se anula podría
llevar a una grave crisis alimentaria a
nivel mundial el informe es de Samuel
Salgado
el mar Negro como escenario clave de
confrontación en la guerra el ministro
de relaciones exteriores de Ucrania
lanzó una controversial propuesta la
otan que encendió las alarmas en Rusia
el mar Negro es fundamental para hacer
que toda Europa sea pacífica y orientada
hacia el futuro Lamentablemente el mar
Negro también es una prueba de lo rápido
que pueden deteriorarse las cosas Si se
descuidan las amenazas culeva propone
integrar los sistemas de defensa aérea y
antimisiles ucranianos con los aliados
de La otan en el mar Negro y en el mar
Báltico este último controlado en su
mayoría por la otan y con el reciente
ingreso de Finlandia a la alianza
Rusia teme que ocurra lo mismo en el mar
Negro son marítima esencial para el
comercio y para su postura militar el
kremlin respondió a la propuesta de
culeva
el mar Negro nunca se convertirá en un
mar de la otan el mar es compartido por
todas las naciones litorales y debe ser
un mar de cooperación interacción y
seguridad la seguridad debe ser
indivisible
prueba la importancia estratégica al mar
Negro es el acuerdo de granos pactado
paralelamente por Rusia y Ucrania con la
ONU y Turquía la más reciente extensión
del pacto expirará el 18 de mayo y Rusia
se muestra renuente a extenderlo debido
a las restricciones que impiden la
salida de sus granos y fertilizantes
en el campo de batalla bacmut sigue
siendo epicentro de la guerra los rusos
afirman que controlan casi la totalidad
de la ciudad las tropas
aerotransportadas apoyan El Avance de
las tropas de asalto bloqueando el envío
de reservas del ejército ucraniano
abacmut y la posibilidad de una retirada
de las unidades enemigas la caída de las
ciudades de 70.000 habitantes antes de
la guerra sería una victoria simbólica
para Moscú y le daría más fácil acceso a
urbes más grandes de toniesk como
kramatowsk y slobians
y en Rusia el opositor político
encarcelado Alexis navale está
nuevamente en un grave estado salud
según declaró su equipo legal el abogado
de naval ni afirmó que su cliente no
recibe atención médica a pesar de estar
enfermo además aseguró que no excluye un
nuevo intento de envenenamiento contra
navaldi desde Moscú nuestro corresponsal
Xavier colás nos amplía
los colaboradores de Alexa Están
preocupados
y lleva semanas perdiendo peso hasta 8
kilos en las últimas tres semanas desde
su entorno llegan mensajes preocupantes
porque creen que podría estar siendo
víctima de algún nuevo tipo de
envenenamiento esta vez un
envenenamiento lento distinto del que
sufrió en el año 2020 y que casi Le
cuesta la vida al parecer una vani en
los últimos días se ha quejado de
fuertes dolores en el estómago desde la
cárcel donde está recluida unos 250
kilómetros de Moscú aseguran que no le
están maltratando pero el hecho es que
el viernes pasado hubo que llamar a una
ambulancia para que el líder opositor
fuese atendido desde el entorno de
alexina además que el líder opositor no
tienen estos momentos acceso ni a la
comida que le están enviando ni a los
medicamentos aquí así que solo Depende
de lo que ahora mismo le están
suministrando en la prisión
en otras noticias este jueves dos ong
publicaron un reporte sobre el alarmante
aumento de las ejecuciones en Irán de
acuerdo a las dos organizaciones Teherán
ejecutó acerca de 600 personas en 2022
incluyendo un marcador repunte desde que
comenzaron las protestas contra el
gobierno en septiembre tras la muerte de
la joven kurdo iraní
un escalofriante informe elaborado por
dos grupos juntos contra la pena de
muerte e Irán Rights evidencia Un
aumento del 75% de las ejecuciones en
Irán el año pasado sobre todo desde que
comenzaron las protestas a Escala
Nacional en septiembre tras la muerte de
Max a mini bajo custodia policial los
autores del informe afirman que Teherán
está recurriendo a la pena capital para
sofocar la revuelta
la pena de muerte se utiliza para
intimidar a la población
para demostrarle que el gobierno tiene
el control sobre su vida o su muerte
amnistía internacional afirma que este
año las autoridades iraníes han
ejecutado al menos a 94 personas solo en
enero y febrero las minorías étnicas
representan una proporción alarmante el
30% pertenecen a los grupos kurdo y
balucci otros grupos son los alguacies y
los aceríes
estas minorías parte del Mosaico
multiétnico de Irán tienen
reivindicaciones políticas algunos
quieren la independencia o más autonomía
y la única forma de silenciarlas es la
pena de muerte
Irán es el segundo país del mundo
después de china con mayor número de
ejecuciones las mujeres están sobre
representadas en el corredor de la
muerte y los menores no están exentos el
nuevo informe denuncia juicios injustos
que a veces duran solo semanas con
presos a menudo obligados bajo tortura a
confesar
y cerramos con deportes porque la
propuesta de celebrar ciertos eventos de
natación en el río sena de París fue
clave para que la ciudad se hiciera con
la sede de los Juegos Olímpicos de 2024
Pero a poco más de un año de las
competiciones los esfuerzos masivos de
limpieza de las aguas están en pleno
apogeo los funcionarios parisinos
esperan convertir uno de los ríos más
románticos del mundo en un lugar apto
para las justas olímpicas
[Música]
estas imágenes se remontan a 1935 y la
ciudad de París ha prometido hacer la
realidad de nuevo
nuevamente los nadadores utilizarán las
aguas del río sena para competir en los
Juegos Olímpicos de 2024
tendremos maratón de natación y triatlón
para los Juegos Olímpicos y paralímpicos
en el sena es vena ha sido un proyecto
durante décadas Y eso es para mí una
demostración fantástica del poder de los
juegos
para alcanzar su objetivo los
funcionarios se han centrado en las
casas ribereñas y los barcos que habían
estado tirando sus aguas residuales y
les han pedido que se conecten a la red
de alcantarillado también han invertido
más de 500 millones de euros en
infraestructura
Contamos con una instalación de
almacenamiento que puede tomar hasta
unos 50.000 metros cúbicos de agua
equivalente a 20 piscinas olímpicas que
nos permitirán contener el agua de
lluvia para evitar que las alcantarillas
se desborden Y luego el agua que se
almacena aquí Se volverá a tratar
progresivamente una vez que deje de
llover para evitar que se contamine el
sena la ciudad dice que sus esfuerzos ya
están dando frutos con la aparición de
más especies de peces y el mejoramiento
en la calidad del agua en algunas áreas
Incluso si no es cristalina
francamente si tomara una medida Y viera
que es buena saltaría y nadaría de
inmediato
los funcionarios esperan que todos los
parisinos puedan nadar en el futuro en
su emblemático río por lo que estudian
cinco lugares para abrirlos al público
un año después de los juegos en 2025
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con más información
[Música]